yeah welcome to this video of 15 minute
game again I don't feel much like short
the time controls it's just too too hot
here feels like the brain is close to
melting so I'm better play something way
I've got a little bit of time to think
so when T form and yeah just taking a
while as well ok Knight f6 so let's go
see form and see what variation he
chooses now at least we don't have
another Slovaks change ok I'll allow the
names oh let's see if you place it yeah
as expected really the most logical move
considering the move autumn ok so I play
III here the tried-and-tested rubenstein
variation which is maybe them yeah the
most classical way to play against them
the names oh ok castled which is a very
flexible move here I can do many things
I'll play a 3 here which now transposase
to the zimage variation usually arising
after for a three but you can also delay
it for a move and this usually leads to
very double-edged positions with white
some ponds being completely destroyed on
the queenside but you get some nice play
in the center yup like some main idea
now is to attack the c-4 porn
with b6 Bishop a6 about d6 this kind of
setup of course is also a possibility so
on I go complete development he might
try for a quickie 5 the sir could be the
idea ok didn't didn't play five so one
question is where should I develop my
night should I go to e2 or to f3 usually
e2 is correct to keep the DF porn
flexible ok i want to spend so much time
on idea three you would have if I've
also and I don't know he form looks a
bit shaky to me ok so I played 5 i'm not
sure if you form is maybe an idea for
black it has got positive sides but also
he has some problems should I play you
for myself this is the sort of easiest
reply just stopping his own advance not
sure I could also play f3 first ok but
let's play you form if he wants to
increase pressure on me for he would
need to play something like rookie aid
and it's not quite sure if the look
really belongs them yeah rupee eight now
so maybe he's trying to take and take on
e4 let's say I would play Knight to f3
at 2 g-3 he might take and take you four
and then f5 um yeah I guess I'm gift as
porn on
proper protection with the f3 in general
this kind of setup with e 5 97 and so on
against the Sammy sure it's it's
playable of course but it's a bit
passive on in comparison to this b6
Bishop a 696 a5 kind of setups there's
no one direct pressure on the c4 porn
which is White's main weakness here it
is fairly close then y term enjoys a
pretty good central dominance at some
yeah somewhat passive for black you can
go night fa to g6 and then stuff or
place c5 completely blocking the
position but it's nothing which really
am puts white under media pressure yeah
not sure what this move has Sam is doing
it sort of runs into an IgG 32 f5 at
some point but um let's castle first ok
IC wants to really do this regrouping of
the night probably 22 g6 and maybe to f4
as well ok mum I play this simple simply
just just developing not doing anything
anything fancy here protect f4 so that
he cannot play night air form and I
still have time to improve my piece
placement before I can try to do
something concrete here
a possible continuation would be lets
say rook to e1 and then 93 to f5 I think
I'll I'll go for this yeah black really
cannot do much this is some gab kind of
basic problem black doesn't have any
meaningful porn it wants us here it
doesn't take anything and he cannot
really attack my center on a move like c
5 i'll just play d5 what he could try as
play something like let's say a 6b five
but ok now you want a 5 which might um
have the idea rook a 6 at some moment
but doesn't look too realistic really ok
I'll go with the Sun mention plan of
getting the Knight to f5 which he always
thought and he needs to take and then I
will have two bishops against two nights
and still install this pawn on f5 which
is also quite annoying uh-huh I think
just isn't just in Bishop g5 a good move
I just detect the the night enter yeah
where should it go think he just he
needs to retreat yeah needs to go back
to to g6 simply and then we'll this is
getting ugly already
I can go on night h5 on so maybe night
h5 getting him into the cell really ugly
pin on f6 yeah this looks terrible for
black is pinning business maybe even
needs to consider queen sack on night h5
just taking this night I don't really
believe it it's working but okay um this
is certainly a good good possibility
night f5 is also still good you have at
nine h5 look sir look Stella we cannot
play h6 also yeah I will say as well
like I would seriously contemplate
taking on age 5 it's it's simply not not
working but I mean you give away the
Queen for 2 minor pieces but the
position is not really a so great for
this kind of material balance black's
pieces don't have so yeah so good down
outposts secure outposts in fact you in
this position I'm already threatening
Bishop f6 winning immediately Bishop f6
g takes f6 what I think this will
threatened take Bishop f6 takes f6 Queen
h 6 squared friends made and she cannot
cover it really only with Queen f8 and
then Knight f6 is also checkmate all
right then this move just wins I know
maybe he mainly considered night eggs
f6 but this should win instantly really
don't see a defense yeah now we let the
clock run down to zero I don't hope this
will happen really he actually greeted
me before the game so don't expect any
unsportsmanlike reasons yeah it's um
yeah it's just winning up to this Queen
age six I'm threatening checkmate and
can only prevent it from move with this
check checkmate and then this is a mate
yeah well nigh to h4 was just down a
real lemon this is move if you play some
normally I think why should have yeah
nice position but it's not not winning
or anything I I really prefer why
doesn't one from my my chest taste tells
me that white is rather clearly better
but I think it's um it's probably still
okay for black it's just very passive
you cannot really do anything you're
just standing basically in the waiting
developments and this is why I'm mostly
top in this kind of position this is
what what black mainly goes for say this
kind of setup and then Knight a5 to put
pressure on the c4 porn probably ninety
six at some point also taking c4 and if
white goes f4u player five so block to
block this F porn from advancing and
this is some yeah the main line of the
same
should considered to be okay for black
and some it's all rather complicated and
unclear um yeah White has those
structural problems but he's got two
bishops and some dynamic possibilities
yeah this is just far more active in
comparison to the game the game does the
setup Molly he develops his pieces but
it's it's black doesn't put any pressure
on on White's weaknesses so i can just
occupy the center and and here this is
already a bit a bit of annoying let's
say black place and nothing move like
like b6 just to show it not f5 and what
I cannot really take it do you think it
needs to go here if he takes then I know
maybe even g4 some preparation move and
then then coming here g45 black it's
just terribly passive and watches really
why does 2pm preferred him so he needs
to on 95 on 95 drop back here and then I
can think about how to further improve
this position it's even possible maybe
to just just push pawns here this kind
of stuff it's yeah like it's just
employing a sit and wait strategy you
cannot do anything active and I have
possibilities with g5 later after some
preparation I have time I can maybe
improve the ropes in a way this way or
swing the Queen over here whatever I can
really attack at it will and black cami
was just defending on his last three
ranks
yeah okay thanks for watching and talk
to you soon with a new video